welcome to the second lecture I was
warned there would be exponential decay
in the size of the audience but I don't
think we've quite reached that level so
today's lecture will be review of
mathematics of mathematical background
needed for the subsequent series and
it's more or less standard measure and
integration theory so indeed if you've
taken courses on this stuff you can
safely skip it I was warned that some
people have not do not remember you know
continuous mathematics so that's why I
put together this lecture just to bring
everybody up to this on the same page in
terms of mathematical background okay so
you measure an integration first you
have to turn it on okay so here's a
quick outline of the topics I'm going to
cover I'll talk about measurable spaces
first and then I'll introduce the
concept of measure which is now trying
to give a quantitative notion of size to
certain sets and then of course one of
the prime uses of measure theory is to
define a theory of integration so that's
what we will cover and finally I will
introduce the rad on nicotine theorem I
won't prove anything because that would
then make it a semester long course I
will instead try to sort of state the
important facts and give some feeling
for how one goes about proving things
okay so what is measure theory we want
to define a notion of size two sets so
that we can use it for various purposes
like integration of geometry computing
areas or for of course probability now
one could imagine counting the number of
points but this is really useless for a
continuous space and it is what the
there is a measure called counting
measure and it's usually there as a
counter example do anything reasonable
it's not got any other real purpose so
what we really want to do is generalize
the notion of length or area or volume
in some way that applies to set
not nice not you know cubes or spheres
or circles we want to ask things like
what is the size of the rational numbers
for example as a subset of the reals
okay so in particular what is the size
length of the rational numbers between 0
& 1 the word length is in quotes here
because normally one thinks of length as
being associated with intervals but
still I would like some notion of size
for all these sets that on our familiar
sets matches up with the usual notion of
length but on these unfamiliar sets or
sets which we normally do not think of
geometrically we still want to define
some sensible notion of size and we want
a consistent way of assigning all these
sizes but sadly the first thing we hit
is a proof that not all sets can be
given such a sensible size which
generalizes the notion of length of an
interval so the precise statement is a
theorem due to vitaliy which says there
is no translation invariant measure
defined on the on the real line such
that it gives the lengths of intervals
okay so that's simply not on and it's a
it's a nice example you can look it up
all over the place Wikipedia for example
which has a not so nice proof but anyway
it's a fairly easy thing that you can do
with using the axiom of choice to
construct such a set an example of a non
measurable set so right off the bat we
have to give up on this idea of
assigning a size to everything we have
to instead pick out some sensible family
of sets which are well-behaved enough
that we can measure them and that is the
essence of measure theory so we want
sets our lives of set satisfying
reasonable axioms and we will deem those
sets to be measurable and we won't try
to measure everything only the sets in
that we have deemed to be measurable and
the key concept is that once try to work
with things that are countable so
countable the closure under countable
unions will be key to this definition of
what constitutes measurability
so with that preamble let me plunge into
the definition so a measurable space is
just a
equipped with a family of subsets which
we call a sigma algebra or sigma field
satisfying the following axioms first of
all you would like the empty set to be
measurable and hopefully its measure
will turn out to be 0 that will turn out
to be one of the axioms we would like
closure under complementation so if a
set is measurable then its complement
should be measurable and right away you
see a stark contrast with what is done
in topology where of course the
compliment of an open set except in
exceptional circumstances is not also
open and then as I said before closure
under countable unions so if I take a
family of sets each of which is in my
designated family of measurable sets and
I take their Union then I would like
that Union to be measurable or in my
family as well so that's a measurable
space set equipped with these three
things I only mentioned unions here but
of course the fact that I'm closed under
complementation implies that it is
immediately closed under intersection as
well so I don't have to state that as a
separate condition so there's some
obvious things that follow so if I take
any collection of sigma-algebra Zona set
and intersect them and look then at the
intersected family that's also a sigma
algebra ok absolutely any collection
doesn't there's no size bound on this so
if I take any collection of Sigma
algebra on a set and intersect them I
get a Sigma algebra which means I can
define a notion of Sigma algebra
generated by a set by a family of sets
so I take absolutely any family of sets
that I want I look at all the Sigma
algebra that contain that particular
family how do I know there are any well
the full power set of course is an
example of a Sigma algebra and it'll
contain any family that I've chosen so I
know that's not an empty collection I
intersect all the Sigma algebra is
containing my family script F and this
has to be a Sigma algebra right what I
just said
and clearly it is the smallest one
containing that and we'll write that as
Sigma of F the Sigma algebra generated
by F ok so this is a very important
point you
pick any family you feel like there
would be some sigma-algebra that it
generates no measurable sets once you
define them even the Borel sets are
complicated beasts it's very hard to say
oh this is what a typical Burrell set
looks like in fact things get worse as
you go higher up the hierarchy and
there's a beautiful subject called
descriptive set theory which is all
about how difficult it is to describe
sets so the descriptive name so
measurable sets are complicated beasts
and we don't want to talk about the
typical measurable set we would rather
say look I've got the simple family of
sets that generate the Sigma algebra of
interest and I'd rather work without
generating family and as far as possible
we will try and do that that we will try
and look for families of simple assets
that generate the Sigma algebra in
question and do everything like defining
measures on those simpler families so
examples well here's the most trivial
Sigma algebra I take the empty set
that's the only thing I was forced to
put into every Sigma algebra and of
course complementation will then force
the whole space to be there so this is a
perfectly useless Sigma algebra but it
is a Sigma algebra at the other extreme
the full power set is also a Sigma
algebra so these are the kinds of
examples that when mathematicians give
them to you you feel like throwing
things at them because they are
unenlightened examples so let's have a
slightly more interesting one as I said
very hard to describe Sigma algebra
except by saying aha the Sigma algebra
generated by this and that so every
single description of a Sigma algebra
that I will give will be of that form so
one of the favorite ones for any
analysis class is the so-called Borel
algebra of the real line so what you do
is you take the open intervals you take
this as you're generating family there's
absolutely no reason by the way why the
generating family so you should itself
be countable so you take the open sets
to be a generating family and the
algebra that you get is called the Borel
algebra I could have as well taken the
closed sets it makes no difference or
the half open half closed and it doesn't
matter at all because
of closure under complementation there
is another sigma-algebra a very popular
in measure theory of the real line
called the lebesgue algebra which is
much bigger and I won't describe it in
detail but I will give you a quick well
I'll give you the reason why it had to
be invented so ultimately you will
describe measures you will start
assigning sizes to these things and then
there will be some sets non-empty sets
of measure zero and this has the
annoying feature that there are sets of
measure zero you'd like to say well if
set has measure zero surely its subsets
have measure zero but some of them turn
out to be in fact not measurable so you
have to do something to complete the
measure space so that you can say
sensibly look if a set as measure zero
all its subsets have measure zero so if
you do this process to the Borel algebra
you get the more used lebesgue algebra
but I will always use the Borel algebra
in today's discussion and subsequently
okay so this is the lebesgue Sigma
algebra that I've mentioned just now now
here is another Sigma algebra that
arises quite a lot in computer science
especially for people studying processes
well processes where you have time steps
and things are happening at each instant
of time so you have sequences of
something or the other sequences of
actions perhaps from drawn from some
alphabet and again we describe the the
algebra by giving you a generating
family and the way we define the
generating family is this so let's say
we have some alphabet a of actions and
we're looking at a infinity which is the
space of all finite and infinite
sequences of actions and we want to make
this into a measurable space so we will
define a an order relation we will say a
word the finite word is the prefix of
another word then W is less than u okay
so we get this notion of prefix and now
we'll define
sets of finite or infinite words being
all words such that they extend the word
in question so this up arrow notation
says you fix some W some word and then
you look at all possible extensions of
it
you can visualize it as something like
this some peculiar reason these things
are called cylinder sets to me they look
more like wine glasses but maybe that's
just me but these sets generate a
sigma-algebra
and this is the sigma-algebra one
typically works with when one is
assigning probability measures to spaces
of sequences okay once again there was
no better way to describe it than by
telling you a simple generating family
so now some variations on the concept of
Sigma algebra one very useful kind of
family of sets are things called
monotone classes and basically instead
of allowing you closure under arbitrary
unions I'm going to insist that the
unions be nested okay perhaps increasing
and then I will write this notation a
and up arrow a meaning the a ends form a
nested family and their Union is a and
similarly the down arrow notation means
it's a downward nested family and their
intersection is a so it's like
approaching a from below or from above
so these are called up and down arrows
so if I have a collection of sets that's
closed under both these kinds of arrows
it's called a monotone class okay so
it's not a Sigma algebra but it's a
closely related beast and again
arbitrary intersections of monotone
class is a form of monotone class so you
can have the set the monotone class
generated by a family of sets now if you
take a family of sets closed under
complements and only finite unions you
get what's called a field of sets
there's a big conflict between
terminology used by analysts and and
algebra so these are not fields as an
algebra similar but they're not the same
thing
so why do I mention all the
if I have a sigma-algebra it is a
monotone class automatically and if I
have a monotone class which also happens
to be a field then it's automatically a
sigma-algebra so these are not exactly
the same concept but closely related and
working with monotone classes is often
very useful and in particular this
theorem is often used to go between
these two kinds of structures
importantly if I have a field of sets
then the monotone class that it
generates is the same as the Sigma
algebra that it generates so that's one
of the cases where it might be more
convenient to generate a monotone class
than a Sigma algebra here are two even
more obscure but interesting families of
sets PI systems and lambda systems so a
PI system a grandiose name is just a
family of sets closed under finite
intersections my god how much simpler
can you get that's all it is closed
under finite intersections ok sounds
like that can't be useful for anything
but it is so the open intervals of the
real lines form a PI system and of
course we already know that that
particular PI system generates a Borel
algebra so here's an example of an
interesting Sigma algebra that we care
about generated by a PI system and and
this basic slogan is that PI systems are
much easier to describe but they can
generate complicated Sigma algebra so we
should try to look for PI systems that
generate the Sigma algebra that we care
about and later on I will give you a
theorem explaining why I love PI systems
a lambda system this is a slightly more
weird thing is a family of subsets
containing the whole space closed under
complements just like a Sigma algebra
and closed on the countable unions part
of pairwise disjoint sets and not
arbitrary ones ok who cares so the point
is if you've got something that is a PI
system and a lambda system then it's a
sigma algebra and quite often you want
to try to prove something is a sigma
algebra
you end up proving it this way and here
is a famous theorem due to Dinkin so if
you have a PI system and you have a
lambda system and it's happens that the
PI system is contained in the lambda
system then the Sigma algebra generated
by the PI system is also contained in
that lambda system does not sound like
such a useful theorem but in fact it is
and many of the things that I state
later on which are manifestly important
theorems are proved by using this it was
quite an interesting experience for me
teaching this material because I taught
it as a computer science class and
several of the students were actually in
the math program and we're also taking
analysis for at the same time and they
would learn my proofs which often used
the lambda PI theorem and they would go
to the analysis class and stick their
hands up and say why don't you use the
parameter pi theorem and finally I
managed to get an irate email from the
analysis prof okay so this sorry
this one it's not very easy at all
no you meet it follows from this I don't
think so I mean there's a clearly a
major ingredient but no no it's not
trivial right so these are the spaces
one is working with I still not have not
defined measures but and we are going to
have to start understanding how these
measure spaces hook together and of
course we have to understand what are
the functions that mediate between these
spaces so this morning Samson said I
have D category fide my lecturers and I
could see the sigh of relief on many
faces some of them not so silent so I am
recategorize everything so all this pure
analysis that was so free of category
theory is going to be category 5 so here
is the first step which is to start
talking about arrows between measurable
spaces right so I will use the word
arrow I wish I had a picture of st.
Sebastian to show you the pain that
arrows can cause but arrows here are are
fundamental to at least to my way of
thinking so a measurable function
between two measures faces basically it
says that the inverse image of a
measurable set from one sigma-algebra
has to be measurable in the first Sigma
algebra okay so this should remind you
of the notion of continuous function
from topology inverse images of opens
are open in topology inverse images of
measurables
are measurable in measure theory ok so
some people might wonder why is it like
this why backwards but of course the
same people have argued with me that the
definition of continuous should be
direct images of open sets should be
open and I spend a long time trying to
persuade them otherwise but there are
physicists so they always know better
than me but anyway what one can say here
is that X is an F inverse B if and only
if f of X is in B and this
for anything analogous to that if you're
working with forward images so I think
it's kind of compelling to use the
inverse image in this place after all
it's exactly why in programming language
semantics you give four triples and give
semantics of assignment statement in
terms of a backward flow I should
mention that older books particularly
how much this book gives a more general
definition which says that the inverse
image of an open set has to be lebesgue
measurable which is a much bigger Sigma
algebra than Borel measurable that's a
dreadful definition it encompasses more
functions so he can integrate more
things but it's not compositional and
you know since since I want to be
categorical I do want a notion that
composes so I will use this definition
so I see that all the modern books
including ones who have no categories
for miles
still use this definition and not the
almost one
so measurable spaces and measurable
functions form a category so examples of
measurable sets
sorry measurable functions if I take a
space with a measurable set then the
indicator function the function that's
one if you're in the set and zero if
you're outside it is automatically a
measurable function if I look at real
valued measurable functions so the when
I say whenever I say real valued
measurable I'm always mean the por el
algebra on the rails so the sum and
product of real valued measurable
functions is measurable if we take
finite linear combinations of indicator
functions we get so-called simple
functions these are also measurable
functions and in particular they have a
finite range of values namely the yeah
they have a finite range so one
important thing is to study the
convergence properties so if I take a
family of measurable functions which
converges point-wise to a function f and
if all the f in the sequence are
measurable functions then so is the
thing to which it converges
absolutely not true of continuous
functions it's easy to make continuous
functions that converge to it to a step
but measurable functions are nastier
beasts so they can be much more jagged
and hence this kind of jump is not a
problem at all and you will get
convergence so this is a stark
difference with the notion of continuity
it turns out you can actually say
something strong about simple functions
so it's not just that measurable
functions converge to measurable
functions
you give me any positive measurable
function I can find a family of simple
functions positive of course that will
converge point wise to that and if you
have a function that's sometimes
positive and sometimes negative I can
break it into its positive piece a
negative piece and approximate them
separately so basically you can adopt a
slogan yeah measurable functions might
be complicated but they're always point
wise limits of simple functions so
that's a nice thing it's always nice to
think that there are simple things that
that get you to the complicated things
it's finite linear combination of
characteristic functions so it has a
finite number of jumps
it was characteristic function is like
that one jump simple functions will have
some finite number of such jumps and
that's it so it's just a linear
combination of SIP of characteristic for
indicator functions and this fact is the
secret to define named lebesgue
integration which is which I will do in
one slide not one slide from now but on
one slide what I get there okay so
finally it's time to measure things so a
probability measure or a measure in
general we typically use the Greek
letter mu is a set function that means
do the sets in my chosen Sigma algebra
it assigns numbers either between 0 and
infinity or 0 and 1 if I'm doing
probability theory and I've written this
closed interval notation meaning I
accept infinity itself as a possible
value for the size of a set for example
for the whole real line I might want to
say it has infinite measure so the
important condition is that if I take
any family countable or pairwise
disjoint sets so there's no question of
over counting by the overlaps so
comfortable family of pairwise disjoint
sets then the measure of the union is
just the sum of the measures of the
individual pieces so this is the
simplest thing you could expect ok and
it's your intuition about intervals
should be may give you a warm feeling
about this definition because if I have
the length of you know somebody's joined
intervals I should just add them up it's
only when they start overlapping and and
scrunching together that that I might
start worrying but if these are pairwise
disjoint there's nothing to worry about
and I normally once sees this stated as
an axiom but I'm allowing these unions
to be over an empty family so I get the
empty set and so this follows okay so if
I take a set equipped with the
sigma-algebra
and a measure defined on those
measurable sets I get what's called a
measure space so now that's the full
apparatus that I can use for doing
everything
I claimed I wanted to do measure an
integration so far gosh yes you to ask
you that the measure of everything is
one did I not say that so I did say zero
okay right so yes so a probability
measures so this is well thank you for
asking that because I want to emphasize
this so for a probability measure I'm
going to say insist that the measure of
the whole space is one so there's
nothing missing sometimes and especially
I do this a lot
I consider sub probability measures
where the measure of the whole space
might be a bit less than one I'm not
sure what a bit means less than one and
perhaps in a computational situation you
can imagine some kind of process that's
computing along and then you have some
probability distribution on the final
results but you want to leave some of
the mass missing because it might
correspond for example to a
nonterminating computation so in that
case it would be more appropriate to
consider these sub probability measures
and sub probability measures give you
also a rich algebra which I will talk
about I think tomorrow right thank you
so as is customary in maths we give you
we start you off with a meaningless
example so here is an example that you
can always define so this is called the
Dirac distribution or Dirac measure so
what this does is it says all the the
measure is concentrated on a single
point so the way you define the measure
is you take your Sigma algebra and you
say if the set contains that point it's
measure is 1 and if it doesn't its
measure is 0 okay so this is sometimes
called the point mass as you might guess
from the name and also from the use of
the word mass physicists came up with
this though they had a screwy way of
defining it they said it's a function
that is zero everywhere shoots off to
infinity
zero and it shoots back down and then
continues at zero and somehow its
integral manages to be one now it
requires quite a lot of wine to believe
that this is a sensible definition but
as a measure it makes perfect sense okay
note also that if I think of this as a
two variable gadget and I fixed the a
then this is and let the X vary then
this is just a characteristic function
of a if I fix the X and at the a very
then it's the Dirac measure concentrated
at the point X so this is a nice thing
so there are some nice properties that
measures satisfying okay first of all
monotonicity so let's fix some let's fix
some measure space so you have a set
sigma-algebra
and a measure and we will write capital
ABC tip for typical sets always assumed
to be in my Sigma algebra if a is
contained in B then it's very intuitive
to that the measure of a should be
smaller than the measure of B okay so
this is just a kind of positivity
property some people do consider signed
measures where a piece of the space has
some negative math so of course
including it might lower your math but
we're looking at positive measures and
of course in quantum mechanics it gets
even more exciting when you have complex
valued measures but we are not doing
those things here now what about these
continuity properties so remember the up
arrow notation so this signifies that
the family a n index by the natural
numbers is nested increasing okay so a
one sitting inside a two etc and then
I'm taking the union of all of them
this can be relatively easily proven
that if you take the limit of the
measures of those index of the sets in
the family you will get exactly the
measure of the limiting set okay so this
is exactly a continuity property
also if you insist on the other kind of
approach to a set not from below but
from above so I have a nested downward
family that's whose intersection gives
me a and here I need a caveat that I
didn't need before if the measure of the
first set is is finite then also the
same limiting property holds let's see
perhaps I owe you a counter example
indicating why I need that caveat
so consider the real line with its usual
measure and look at the interval 0
infinity and then 1 infinity and then 2
infinity and so on they're nested
downwards each of them has infinite
measure so the limit of all these
infinities is infinity however the
intersection is empty and has measure 0
so this theorem would be blown if I
didn't insist on this so these are
interesting exercises to prove and when
you prove it you will see how you use
that condition in that second proof but
you would not have used needed to use
any such thing in the first proof
okay so here is the first digression
this is purely for fun digression I'm
not going to use this concept but it
seemed to me of emerging importance and
I see we're located across the street
from the business school so it was in
the business school that this theory was
developed not this one but it's in the
economics community so consider the
problem of combining probability and non
determinism right so you say oh I have
this quantified notion of uncertainty
which is captured by a probability
distribution but in addition I have some
totally unquantified uncertainty as well
so how would I describe such a thing so
you might say look I have I don't know
17 different measures probability
measures that I'm working with and one
of them gets picked arbitrarily in some
unquantified way how do I make estimates
so you might say all right so you give
me a set and I'll compute its measure by
all these measures and take the soup or
depending on the application perhaps the
int is more appropriate depending on
what kind of estimate you want but let's
say you take soups well so this in fact
what's done by several people including
me and my co-workers in analyzing the
interaction of probability and non
determinism so you do this and you can
right away ask is it a measure the
answer is no it's absolutely not going
to be additive not even finitely
additive forget about countable
additivity but it does satisfy
monotonicity that's easy to see and
actually satisfies both continuity
properties up and down so that's nice
it's not Sigma additive but it does have
it's not a wild completely wild beast
you can actually do stuff with it
because of these monitor Nyssa t and
continuity properties so Gustav's okay
oximeter is this he defined a capacity
now call - okay capacity as a set family
that's either szabo super additive so
there were two kinds plus monotone and
he insisted on both continuity
properties so one interesting thing is
to ask so does every capacity arise some
combination of measures whose soup I
take and for a while I thought the
answer was yes but then my extremely
clever collaborator gave me a counter
example on a three point set so I will
leave that as a exercise if you want so
it's possible to give examples of
capacities that are not realizable as
the soup of any number of measures so
who cares about these things why do
economists care so apparently so one of
the things that you can do with
capacities is develop a theory of
integration and it's quite an
interesting theory you lose linearity
but you have some limited version of it
and and it's not again
not as nice as the standard theory of
integration but not completely wild and
it turns out that economists have
developed this theory a lot and they
particularly use it to analyze risk it's
something they should be worried about
okay let's get back to our which is the
place where interesting measure Theory
first happens and let's try and define
answer questions like I asked at the
beginning can we define a sensible
notion of length for example of the
rational numbers okay so we're going to
define something called an outer measure
I'll write mu star this star suggests
that it's an outer measure so what do
you do you have some set and you're
trying to figure out how big is this set
so you say look I know how to measure
the length of intervals intervals have a
length that's a well-defined concept so
I take this horrible set that I might be
looking at and I'll say I will cover it
with intervals okay I might overestimate
it because I might spill over the edges
of this very jagged set but it'll be at
least an upper bound on the size of the
set and then I will look at all possible
ways of covering it and take the info of
the total length okay and then I will
get something called the outer measure
so it is easy to see that the rationals
have outer measure zero so let me try
and do this I want to write on the board
I will use a hand waving argument so I
wave my hands like this so how do you do
it you enumerate the rationals they're
countable and then I claim that you give
me any epsilon however small I will
cover all the rationals with with
intervals whose total length is less
than epsilon I look at the first
rational and I cover it with an interval
of length epsilon over 4 then I look at
the next rational and cover it with
interval of length epsilon over 8 and I
keep going this way so that thing adds
up to epsilon or half epsilon if I've
done my arithmetic incorrectly but
definitely not more than epsilon yes yes
sorry yes yes sorry no I did not be
finite family countable family yeah that
was a grave omission so this shows that
for any epsilon you give me I can cover
the the rationals where the family of
intervals of length epsilon so the in
overall the length of all possible
covering families is indeed 0 and so the
outer measure of the rationals is 0 and
that's an upper bound on any sensible
measure you can give so you can say the
measure of the of the rationals is 0 now
of course other sets might have outer
measures more than 0 it might be some
finite number does this give us a way of
measuring all possible sets the thing
that I claimed was impossible so it
turns out no it is defined on all sets
because I can of course cover any set I
want it might well be that the outer
measure is infinity but the point is
this mu star thing is not additive so it
does not give a measure as we have
demanded it on all its it's defined on
all sets but it's not a measure it does
however satisfies subadditivity so if I
take a family of sets and take a
countable family and take their unions
then then this inequality holds
sometimes forget to say countable I will
trust Peter to harass me every time I
forget that okay no I don't even care
about this joint here no I don't need it
it's important to say it for additivity
yes but for subadditivity who cares
you're over counting anyway okay so we
define an outer measure to be a set
function satisfying monotonicity
countable subadditivity and defined on
all sets and now we have to go from
these outer measures to real-life
measures obviously we can't do this for
all sets so we have to say okay so this
outer measure it's going to be a good
measure but not on everything we have to
identify what are the good sets how do
we figure out what are the good sets
they are the ones that split all sets
nicely what does this mean so this is
what it means there are some special
sets a with this property they split
everything nicely so you take a generic
set E and it will turn out that the
outer measure of e splits nicely into
the sum of the outer measure of e
intersected with a and E intersected
with a compliment it's a very special
set that that might have that kind of
property so we call the collection of
all such sets Sigma and for those sets
we'll say our your measure is in fact
your outer measure and somewhat
non-trivial theorem that you can prove
is that now you get a bona fide measure
space so in particular it means that the
family of such sets like that is indeed
a Sigma algebra okay so this is a long
ish not fantastically difficult but a
proof that roughly takes 40 minutes
represent okay so this is how you go
from outer measures to measures or one
way
so the standard proof does not use the
lambda PI theorem but proof I thought
that I thinks is the when I got the I
right email
right you never measure adjust the old
imagine and you never measure
required that they be the same where you
get don't think so no but if you do find
into them if you have a space for the
whole measure of the whole world is
finite and you define the inner measure
to be essentially the complement of the
outer measure of the complement then
what you say will agree with this is
that that's not by the way it's what
this fitting is trying to tell you yes
that's integration but we're just
measuring yeah no no I think we will
argue about arm-wrestle if not and
nothing else over this later okay so if
you apply this to our with the outer
measure you get indeed the standard
lebesgue measure on the VAR l sets okay
now how do you define measures I told
you we like to define measurable spaces
by starting with some simple sets and
generating them we would also like to
define measures on those simple sets and
extend it to the generated sigma-algebra
it would be a pain to try to define it
directly on the sets we've already said
they said the sets are complicated to
describe so we don't want to define the
measures on these sets we want to define
them on simple and nice sets so we have
a number of things called extension
theorems that tell you if you have a
nice generating family then you can
extend the set function on it do the
whole sigma-algebra
so one example of nice is a family of
sets is called a sigma-ring or semi-ring
if it contains the empty set
it is closed under intersection so so
far it's just a PI system and then it's
got this slightly peculiar thing so
supposing I've got a contained in B and
then I look at this the set difference
of B minus a then there are finitely
many pairwise disjoint sets all of them
in my family such that this cement this
a not symmetric difference the set
difference is the union of those things
I and B are also from a Prius yeah so
you might think this is just like a
completely weird thing but there's a
picture that makes this clear or keys to
an example
and the example is you look at
rectangles access aligned rectangles
okay there's a and B and then you look
at B minus a and you get a gadget like
that and of course you can now split it
up into disjoint rectangles so this is a
this how I remember watch what the rule
is okay so it tells you it's not a
completely stupid definition there are
natural examples of it so the claim is
if you've got a set function defined on
a semi-ring satisfying finite additivity
the obvious property and just countable
Saavedra tivity then it will extend
uniquely to a measure on the whole
generated sigma-algebra
and this is what we often do so in fact
when we looked at those wine glasses
which generated the sigma-algebra on the
on sequences they actually it's easy to
see they form a semi ring so you can
define probability distributions on
those things easily because finite
sequences yes we know how to define
probabilities on those and it extends
uniquely to a measure on the whole space
why I like PI systems so quite often you
end up defining two measures on a Sigma
algebra and you are wondering are they
the same now supposing that Sigma
algebra is generated by a PI system so
remember this notation Sigma of P means
two Sigma algebra generated by P and
supposing P happens to be a PI system
then if these two agree on that PI
system they will agree on the whole
Sigma algebra so that's lovely you've
got these really simple sets you just
have to check that they agree there and
they agree everywhere do note however
that you have to know in advance that mu
1 and mu 2 are measures so this is not
an extension theorem you already know
these things are measures you're just
wondering are they the same measure or
not and this theorem this is a corollary
of the lambda PI theorem
so here's an example of a measure on HT
I think I'm going to skip it it's kind
of obvious and I need to do integration
so remember what I said about arbitrary
measurable functions they can be
approximated by simple functions so
let's just pretend we're always talking
about positive things because otherwise
I have to split it into positive
negative negative pieces and work with
them separately so we just have the
positive ones so they're always
approximated they're always approximated
from below by simple functions so that's
how we're going to define integration in
the same way so you fix a measure space
you define the characteristic function
as usual and now you say well what's the
integral of a characteristic function
it's 1 on the set and 0 outside the set
it should just be the size of the set
all right this is a I would say a
compelling definition or or sometimes
you find the preachers whose notes for
the sermon says argument week here shout
like hell so this is what I'm doing here
so so the integral of a characteristic
function is just a measure of the set
simple functions of finite linear
combinations of these characteristic
functions so these are now finite sums
ok and so what should the integral of a
simple function be especially if you
have in mind that the notion of
integration you want should be linear
well it should be just the same linear
combination of the measures of the sets
there's this problem here I mean because
the same simple function might have many
different representations and you have
to check that actually the integral you
get is doesn't depend on how its
represented like that and that's a not
difficult but super annoying exercise
but it can be done so there's a natural
notion of integral of simple functions
ok so that's now as I said every
positive measurable function is the
point-wise limit of a sequence of simple
functions so for a positive measurable
function f we will define the integral
as the soup of the integrals of the
simple functions that are approximating
it again
you better prove independence of which
family you pick and then there are some
things I'm skating over so for a general
measurable function we can split it into
its positive and negative pieces and
compute those integrals separately so
I'm skated over some issues about
integrability because if things you know
if you end up having to add subtract one
infinity from another then it gets dicey
so you have to be a little bit more
careful than what I have said here but
at least morally this is how integrated
lebesgue integration works why do we do
this I know
well mentioned Riemann integration so
Riemann integration works by dividing
the the domain this is working by
dividing the range and the advantage of
this is that it's much gives you much
stronger properties for interacting with
limits interplay between integration and
limits works much more nicely than with
Riemann integrals so the paradigmatic
example of this is the monotone
convergence theorem so it says that
supposing you have a sequence of
measurable functions which are
increasing point-wise okay
and damn I made a serious error this
should be strictly less than I want it
to be finite not less than or equal to
but I got carried away with latex so if
the soup point-wise soup is a function f
remember I already told you that that
function f is going to be measurable
then the integral of that limit function
is the limit of the end of the integrals
of the approximating functions so this
is a nice convergence theorem and in
fact one can use this theorem to prove
that integral is linear so it was
defined to be linear on simple functions
but then you can use it to prove that
it's linear on arbitrary measurable
functions now this monotone convergence
theorem is super useful there is a more
powerful theorem that uses this in its
proof called the dominated convergence
theorem but already the monotone
convergence theorem gives you a nice
mantra for proving a bunch of things so
let me give you an example of a result
that is not particularly dramatic or
that useful for anything I'm going to do
but it's a lovely illustration of this
mantra okay so supposing I've got to
measurable spaces so that should have
been slash and you anyway so supposing
I've got a measurable function defined
on Y okay so I can integrate it there
and supposing I've got I have I already
have this measurable function from X to
Y so now of course whenever I have such
a thing I can push the measure from here
to there
alright simply by using T inverse over I
can use T inverse to pull any set back
here and then measure it with Muzo this
measure mu gets pushed forward and what
I'm saying here is that the measure that
I have here is in fact just the forward
image of this measure mu ok so supposing
I have this so this is called a measure
preserving map then here is a an
equation that holds so if I look at the
composed function f composed with T
is now defined on X I look at it's
integral over the space T inverse P and
I use mu to measure it to compute the
integral this is the same as if I
computed the integral over here okay
this is a simple fact now how do you
prove such a thing
intuitively it looks highly plausible so
you check that this equation holds for
the very simple case of F being a
characteristic function because it's
just a very simple thing right when it's
a characteristic function you can
explicitly compute both sides its mu of
intersection T inverse B or knew of yeah
anyway that's what it is so it's easy to
check this equation for this case and it
turns out that's all you have to do
because after that it all follows from
the mantra so the next thing is used in
tone but preferably in a monotonous
voice it is true for every simple
function by linearity then any positive
measurable function is the limit of
simple functions of Y the monotone
convergence theorem it holds for that
and then it holds for any measurable
function because you can split it into
its positive and negative pieces okay so
you just have to intone all this and it
follows from only this incredibly
trivial thing that you have to check
explicitly okay so now I talked
yesterday quite a bit about conditional
probability and how important it is and
I want to now talk about the
mathematical theorem that lies at the
heart of defining these conditional
probabilities on continuous basis and
that is the red on nikodem theorem so
we will say two measures are mutually
singular basically if their supports are
disjoint okay so this just means they're
kind of defined on completely disjoint
spaces they're not going to be such an
important concept the important part is
we will say a measure is absolutely
continuous with respect to another
measure written in this way it looks
like a much less than symbol or a way
below symbol but it's met at to be
absolutely continuous and what it means
is that if this measure says that a set
has measure zero then that one better do
as well don't be confused by this
notation it could well be that new
actually assigns larger sizes in the
case that it assigns a nonzero size for
example if I say new is defined as 17
times mu then it is also absolutely
continuous with respect to MU but if mu
says hey you're set it has measure zero
nu has to say that as well
okay so absolute continuity so if I
define you for example by saying ah the
way I compute what mu is is by
integrating some function some positive
function with respect to MU over that
set then I get an example of a measure
and this is a case where new will be
absolutely continuous with respect to MU
always right on nikodem theorem says
this always happens this is why one
measure is absolutely continuous with
respect to another so if mu and nu are
let's say finite measures technically
the only lead Sigma finiteness but I
haven't defined this then it can be
decomposed into two pieces one piece
which is singular with respect to the
measure and the other piece is
absolutely continuous with respect to MU
okay so that's the decomposition part
and the second part says that if you've
got that you've got a non-negative
measurable function H such that this mu
ape term is actually just given by
computing that integral so this H
is telling you how to compute the mew
measure with respect to the mute the new
measure with respect to the MU measure
right so it satisfies to say now if I
have you might ask about uniqueness if I
have another such measurable function
with the same property then H and H
Prime will differ at most on a set of MU
measure zero which is a set insensitive
to integration basically so it's almost
everywhere unique so this function H is
called a radon nikodem derivative of Nu
with respect to mu and sometimes people
even write it in this suggestive
notation do not think of this as
anything like a real-live derivative but
it is just a formal notation for the
almost everywhere uniquely defined
function H yes I'm sorry there was there
there is a this should have been nu sub
a sorry this is I just looked at this is
a typo dense slide which I will fix
before I put it up on the webpage
now so you're gonna use this now yes so
let's think about the case well let's
not worry about mutually singular things
we will assume that I've got one measure
that absolutely continues with respect
to another and we're going to use the
read on the current park statement okay
maybe I should
let's see if it looks easier to
understand in blue so I have a measure
new I have another measure mu and
they're related in this way so whenever
new says Sarah whenever Muse has this
set has measure zero then this must also
say that okay so this part is here good
so now the theorem says if I have this
situation then there exists a measurable
function H such that if I want to
compute the measure of any set by this
new I can always compute it by
integrating H with respect to MU over B
so that's and the second thing I said
was this is almost everywhere unique
there might be another one but the
difference between that and this can
only be a set of measure zero as
measured by this measure yeah so
basically it says these things are
tightly coupled and that coupling is
provided by this measurable function H
which will relate them why it's called a
derivative if you write it like this
then you take your physics class and you
go like that I'm showing my what my
origins here
okay but it is what understanding this
because this is a crucial theorem yes
just to comment about the derivative
business if you is ordinary lebesgue
measure measuring intervals the usual
way inexpensive sigma-algebra
now suppose I have some nice smooth
increasing function f and I decide to
measure intervals not by their length
but by how much F increases during that
interval so the F of the right end minus
F of the left end so use that instead of
entering or wife define a measure from
that because I see this function is so
nice and smooth I'll get something
absolutely continuous with respect to a
bank measure and with any luck at all
the rather liquid even derivative of
that would be the derivative of the
function f that I began almost
everywhere almost thank you so how do we
use this to do conditional probability
so supposing I have two continuous
spaces x and y and i have a joint
measure on this space so they're not
necessarily independent I have marginals
which I'll call px and py and supposing
I tell you the x coordinate is this now
the probability of any specific one
point is going to be zero right we
assume that these are not singular
measures concentrated anywhere so I
still have to revise my probability
estimate for the second coordinate and
so I have to come up with a conditional
probability and I can't do the
old-fashioned thing of dividing by the
probability of this space because that
set is zero now if I fix a measurable
subset of a there's a measurable
function which I'll call P sub a which
satisfies this
okay so it'll say for every B if you
want to compute the measure of a times B
the rectangle generated by a and B then
you do it by integrating this thing over
be using the marginal how do I know that
such a function that's what right on
nikodem tell told me it's exactly what
right on nikodem says okay so this is
simply because this measure is
absolutely continuous with respect to
that one okay so this is what tells me
that I can do this and her after I will
write P I'll write these as two argument
things PX b and py a and though i'm
going to think of this now as a
conditional probability density it says
given that the value of x is X little X
or given that the first coordinate is
little X what's the probability that my
second coordinate is in this set P will
be given by this number and similarly
like that so this is how I get
conditional probabilities on continuous
spaces it's through the power of the
radon nikodem derivative we have a
probability space like that so I had a
special case of this rectangle but more
generally I have a probability space I
have a sub sigma-algebra lambda of my
big sigma-algebra and supposing i tell
you for every B in lambda whether the
result is in B or not so I'm giving a
lot of information but only about a sub
Sigma algebra you see this is kind of
what I did before in the previous
example I told you what happened on
vertical strips which is a sub Sigma
algebra of the whole thing so you might
so now so the usual thing that we tell
you hey the result is in this particular
set B what I'm actually telling you is
for a particular very small Sigma
algebra namely empty B B complement in
the whole space whether there for every
one of those sets I'm telling you what's
happening so here I'm just generalizing
that idea and saying instead of that
tiny sub-sigma algebra I'm giving you a
somewhat bigger one and telling you for
every one of those things whether the
result is in the given set or not how do
I revise my probabilities so it turns
out again by right on nikodem
for any a in Sigma there is a lambda
measurable function written like this
such that for any B and lambda the
probability of a and B is given by this
integral and again this is almost P
almost everywhere unique the existence
of so this is the thing that I can
legitimately call the conditional
probability density given the
information I have about the Sigma field
lambda and you can see this is again
giving me kind of P of a and B as I
expected from the even the discrete
notion of conditional probability so
back to the product case which is just a
special example of this so if I fix X I
get a probability measure for a fixed B
it is a measurable function not quite so
for a fixed countable family of
measurable sets we get countable
additivity almost everywhere because
there are on nikodem just guarantees
good behavior almost everywhere but
there are lots of these countable
families and it might happen that we end
up with something that's not a proper
measure anywhere where I want countable
additivity on everything so in fact
while the Raton nikodem theorem is fine
for doing conditional probability and
conditional expectations everything I
said about conditional probability could
be said more generally about conditional
expectations for things that I want to
do next time we need something stronger
that really gives me gadgets that are
measures in the second argument and
measurable functions in the first
argument always okay so these things are
called regular conditional probabilities
and sometimes disintegrations okay so
the existence of this integrations
requires a bit more work than dried or
negative and so when you have this
integrations these statements are true
everywhere so how do we construct
disintegrations you can construct them
on spaces that are equipped with a bit
of extra structure what kind of
structure metrics so this is one of the
places where metrics enters into
probability theory and in particular if
you have a so-called poolish space which
is the topological space underlying a
complete separable metric space
then you can always construct these
disintegrations and i will be
disintegrating tomorrow on these polish
spaces okay so I think I've run a bit
over time remember after the break Mike
miss love will be putting the boot to
the boot camp by covering so it's done
on a certain it's done on all standard
textbooks it's done in all standard
textbooks including mine how hard is it
I don't know the proof is it's not very
hard yes it's it's not where this
definition is more of this a
generalization is more obvious so I so I
don't know that direct answer to the
question as you've asked it but there
are other integrals so there's a
something called the hence talked
integral which is kind of a generalized
Riemann integral for which you can prove
lots of things it's not exactly the same
as the lebesgue integral but there's
lots of things you can do with it but
maybe we should discuss this offline to
prove that Riemann integration and
lebesgue integration agree when you have
a riemann integrable function is not
that difficult so basically they will
agree if the function has I think the
set of discontinuities is a set of
measure zero I remember correctly then
they will agree and that is not very
difficult to prove it's not trivial
either if you were expecting me to prove
it
hmm okay so maybe we should take our
break so we'll be back at 4:30